we got a fun up this week babes we got
uh my shirt i just got back from shark
week if you see the tan we got that
whole entire story i just got back from
the from the netflix is a joke comedy
festival i bombed uh television taping
so it's fun bunch of stories there bunch
of stories there you talk about uh
hatchet throwing and murdering people
and yep and all sorts of fun stuff
bubble wrap i i'm on about 45 minutes of
sleep and i have a headache came
straight from the plane but it's gonna
be fun fun fun he's gonna oh we talked
about the bahamas yeah we talked about
bahamas and your mama and your mama yeah
you know what else is going to be fun
what
watching specially weshy on netflix
correct that's you can watch my comedy
special i'll show you well you can have
a lot of fun on may 24th at the vulcan
in austin texas and may 26th at stand up
live in phoenix uh two days from now on
the 14th i am at the beacon theater in
new york city and the following week i'm
in san diego at the majestic on the 21st
and i am in la at the wilton on the 22nd
also our merch is also available on our
websites just go to the store get it
baby can get it at salvolcanocomedy.com
you get a christy comedy.com you get a
joe derosacomedy.com we got the merch
baby and i'm about to announce 20 cities
next week 20 new cities next week a lot
of you vanessa all the ones even asking
are gonna be there check it out they're
there baby
and pimp has on new pants
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings bae don't be
afraid don't be ashamed don't hesitate
to say hey babe hey babe hey baby hey
baby boy man great till they got a hey
babe i'm sorry so got it i got it i got
it got it yeah i got it all right ready
yeah
why don't they great till they got a hey
baby
i just took a dna test turns out i'm 100
hey babe even when i'm crying crazy yeah
i got boy problems that's a human
you not calling me back
why men great till they got a hey babe
what's up bubbas i got you a gift thank
you my friend i appreciate this i was
given that
by a great i i did a show in tulsa shout
out to also did i have a blast in tulsa
there's a new show coming out called the
tulsa king i think it's you really yes
okay so first of all the venue is so
nice they got me all these gifts
they got professional axe throwing
service whoa and they got me my own axe
with the name on a handle and before and
after the show for like an hour and a
half i was throwing chinese stars
daggers and axes across the room double
fisting everything oh i gotta give you
that i gotta give you the video i have
it just two arms just throwing huge axes
and sticking in the in the wall it's
unbelievable oh my god it was good [ __ ]
good [ __ ] and axe i think having an axe
it's nice having an axe i'd like a ball
and chain
you know what ball and chase i'd like
that sick because a lot of people have
access yeah and and but not what they
don't kill bill stuff yes but a ball and
axe i think that might have been the
worst way to die
in a in a medieval war yeah it's a ball
and axe let me ask you a question he's
easily defended with it with a shield
would you rather fight in a in a in a
new age war or or a medieval war
you have to fight one i gotta go new age
you'd rather fight new age hit me with a
missile you know hit me you know
maybe i get a bullet bullet one but
that's that middle-aged stuff is
that combat's no good that's tough dude
but here's the limbs and you've seen uh
game of thrones sure but if a nuclear
bomb hits you everyone's to die middle
age mid uh me you know the middle ages
by the way i'm also battling middle age
are you battling middle age yeah
you are battling middle age well i guess
so am i 37 that's middle age yeah
because double that is 74
and double me is 90. i'm a man
without a doubt i'm
in the second half i mean it's after
half time for me 100
and i think about that and i get very
depressed and i'll tell you another
thing i am older than 100
of any athlete in all professional
sports every athlete yeah i looked it up
even baseball because sometimes baseball
has an old pitcher no i think i am i
think i am right wow which is
it's crazy so do you want to do a thing
where we try to campaign to just see if
you can be the oldest player to ever
make a professional sport i'll do it i
think you guys are forgetting about
somebody kane tanaka tom brady
tom brady is younger than me though
really he is
mr brady is younger than me i also love
that this fact haunts you i think this
is the fourth or fifth episode
wait we gotta break we gotta figure out
who's the new oldest
now that kane's past it's actually a
brazilian woman that they found they
they found this woman she's 122 years
old what was kane
wait that's what i'm saying she's been
the oldest woman but she was just
discovered recently
so kane tanaka was never really the
oldest woman no it was this brazilian
maria gomez dos reyes is thought to be
121 years old in this picture
um now she's 122. no don't do cane like
that don't do cane dirty well cause i
i've been thinking about this there has
to be somebody older than there's got to
be somebody who's like 140. yeah that
they're still using like a landline they
can't get in touch with nobody yeah if
if they're saying that the richest
people in the world don't want to be on
the list so like you think elon musk is
the richest or you think is that true
that yeah but they say there's people
that got way more money than them they
just don't want to be on no list oh they
don't want anyone to know what they have
so this that's got to be the same for
for the people there's got to be
somebody who lives like deep in the
amazon who's 100 who's 150 yeah
wow that's that's messed up to come out
after kane passes though she's born in
the 1900s
in
in what she said june 16th 1900
right no
yeah
so she's coming up she's gonna be 122
coming up
wow wow she
didn't need to be some type of reality
show about pokemon does she love pokemon
yeah that's what it says
oh wow so does logan paul loves pokemon
yeah yeah shout out logan paul you know
he grows up to be the oldest person in
the world he might at the rate he's
going i think do you think we're living
in the time where
like we'll conquer death in our lifetime
i don't know if in ours
but what do you think would you if they
can get you to
let's say they can get you to 150 right
as a reg okay are you still
are years like 90 to 150 good years or
is it just like are you going to be like
a 90 year old until 150 or is your 120
year old self gonna be like a 60 year
old self
that's a good question i think that
if you told me you could get me to 150
i'd say no
you'd say no i'd say no because because
are the people in my life gonna die i
don't that's what i don't everybody's
gonna come along with oh everyone's
coming with me what i'm saying
i don't want to be at 150 you will loan
no one
nobody will speak to you the world will
pass you by technology you're not gonna
be 140 and learning the new phone
right you're gonna be
alone in the house
unless though yeah but unless because
all the technology with with with um
you know all the cell technology they're
doing the micro chips you might be able
to start to get a lot older like your
body's gonna get older but they could
put a microchip in your brain or
something like that where like your
brain stays young regulates so like yeah
so like it regulates it so like maybe
they can't do anything for the vessel
but the computer in there
maybe they can
you know like you won't your brain won't
be old but your body will be which will
probably be a nightmare that would be
odd to me too like if i was like
bedridden or with a walker or could
barely move but
all of my faculties are completely good
up here and so i just can't i'm like
what's up buddy how you doing i would
love to get up but i can't move i can't
yeah
therapist the patient i worked on that
had a thing called locked-in syndrome no
but tell me now the most terrifying
thing of all time locked in let me guess
what it is you got a guest pimp don't
tell me they stayed frozen at that age
no they
actually they were younger they passed
away and thankfully even their family
was like thank god they passed away
because it was a nightmare it's locked
in syndrome you can either get i think
of a stroke or a neurological disorder
or or head trauma
you get paralyzed every single part of
your body is paralyzed except your brain
is fully functioning and aware and the
only thing can move is your cranial
nerve three the oculomotor nerve so all
you can do is move your eyes back forth
up and down and that's how this person
would communicate through a board that
was set up and their eyes would lock on
a laser yes no but stephen hawking even
had more function than them stephen
hawking at least like they i mean while
stephen hawking was like cirque du
soleil compared to this guy exactly yes
yes stephen hawking was doing the
language how do they communicate through
their eyes so their eyes were there was
a keyboard a letterboard and it would be
you know if you would say you know uh
you know do you feel hot and they write
yes or no with their eyes
i mean
and that person wanted to be alive that
way well they no they didn't or is he
like spelling out kill me with it no i i
don't know that that ever happened but i
remember like when they when he died i
was i was working as a physical
therapist when he died the family
came in like you know died whatever like
they they they had died like uh the
night before and i came into work like
oh so and so died and i was like wow
there's to the family which i was you
know in this home i worked at many
people died with elderly or whatever
and you know families come in and be
upset they came in with a cake for the
staff
they their their loved one had just died
and they came in their the family came
in with a cake
for the staff because they for help
because they were like thank god
they're dead because they did that like
they it was like a horrible existence
that this guy was living so they were
like happy that they were like he's he
has to be out of pain so they i remember
they came in with a carvel cake
you can't do much you could watch tv
maybe
no he wouldn't even do that i don't know
i don't even like we would go in there i
would go in there did it happen after
because of an accident i forgot what
happened with him i think it was he had
a stroke or some type of head trauma go
ahead
this is this a-s-a-m-s-r like somebody
is somebody i'm telling you somebody is
watching this podcast right now
coming their brains out well i feel like
that's normal yeah
yeah
go go uh go to go to hey babe uh hey
gmail.com email us do you come to this
podcast or not
so so i played the cox business center
tulsa ballroom they got me the axe
throwing then they got me all these
gifts i mean dude like 20 gifts oklahoma
is where it's at part of it was thank
you heather i believe it was shout out
heather uh part of it was his suit and i
said you know what i'm actually gonna
mail that home and i'm going to give it
to chris because your career is popping
off right now
there it is folks and also because i
just took a flight and we're trying to
be safe here yeah so i said this is how
i got on the flight that's how i'm
getting off the flight i also don't want
you to hurt a bone in your body ever
yeah i want to protect my little boy i'm
bubble wrapped yeah i'm i'm bubble
wrapped um
i sent it home and i said it's going to
go on the pockets she was a podcast fan
so is she yeah shut up you were good
with axes aren't they pointy they are
but they weren't going at me yo check
this
oh my god
and also like what is the liability on
axe throwing at a live event
but they had chinese stars
what the hell knives so what do you
think the most practical weapon to
defend yourself was after experiencing
oh wow they put they then look at that
yo this is like legitimate
here talking to mike talking to mike
shout out to got wood axe throwing oh
that's fine check that out so what's
your plan for the axe where are you
going to place it you're gonna put it
underneath your bed if anyone tries to
come [ __ ] with you well this is a
hatchet i'm talking you heard that
nice
so i actually threw theirs but i
actually threw mine a bunch too and and
dude you feel you feel like you're in
mid the medieval times because you
understand like like in ancient times
jacksonville if you like stole something
they would take this and cut your hand
off with that yeah like i think they'd
light it on fire it's insane i know it's
a lot of cardio no it is a lot of cardio
you're right and i took and i learned
the different rotations
and like i mean i was look i'm going to
air drop you then all right i'm going to
air drop it drop that air drop it like
it's hot and drop it like it's hot i
don't even know how to air drop so so
zombie apocalypse what are you doing
stars axe
did you do a sword was there a sword
there wasn't a sword there was big big
axes though and hatchets and knives and
the stars are fun you just fling them
you don't really need a skill set for
those yeah but they they do go like they
are very light and they go fast and like
if you missed they would fly past your
target if you were going to get killed
by one thing you're going to get killed
by one thing
or hat yeah if you're going to get
killed by one thing would you rather be
killed by a chinese star a chinese
finger trap or chinese food
how do you get killed by the finger trap
um you starve to death because you can't
use your hands anymore you can't have no
life you have no almost like the guy
just you're locked up
[Laughter]
feel that thing so here's what i'm
asking you okay i now have wow because
all these sponsors and all these things
i have that i have a machete that i got
delivered to the house i have a bunch of
field knives i have all this stuff stuff
right now somebody breaks into my house
okay
i don't have i don't have a gun i don't
have a sword or anything but i have this
you know what this knives downstairs but
i gotta be honest
unless
it was really urgent i don't know if i'd
swing with this because
that is you have to move after that yeah
right you're not gonna
you're not gonna hit someone with a
hatchet
and then they go down
and then you clean it up you get some
clorox cleaned up and then next the next
night you're eating dinner there
you're saying if you bludgeon someone to
death with a hatchet that broke your
house you would have to move out of that
house you gotta you gotta and you
probably gotta go to therapy right i
would i don't think i'm prepared to look
at that yeah i can't do that uh well i
think would you want to move out of the
house because you think that now the
house is haunted by the spirit of the
person you killed i didn't even think of
that that's another thing but i just
think this gruesome thing that happened
that energy and that vision and that
yeah well look at me what would it take
for you if someone broke into your house
and you had to hatch it how far do they
have to go what what does it have to get
to for you to swing this at them
if they try to raid my closet of magic
spoon
honestly then they better give us a call
again ask me again well what would it
take what what the level where would it
have to go for you to swing this if
someone broke into your house if they
tried to get into my hello fresh that's
exactly right
dude if they try to take my raycons
no i think i think personally so what i
did was and i got it's actually on the
way being delivered to my house by the
time this episode comes out to be my
house but i have i have a permit and i
have a buckshot
shotgun coming to the house
yes you can legally get these in new
york
it shoots a [ __ ] shot it's a hunter it's
a buckshot it's a hunting gun it's uh
it's a it's a shotgun that shoots
buckshot so but if you've got speeding
it's it's a
buckshot being a buck like a buck like a
no it's like a block shot this is the
thing because because there's a bucks
yeah so is is it meant to kill it can
kill anyone though so what what the
thought is is if you broke into my house
yeah it's i'm not gonna come down the
stairs in the middle of night and uh not
knowing how to you know use a weapon it
sprays it's spread it sprays so you know
how they say say it don't spray it yeah
almost spray spray it not say anything
yeah because they also they also like
the um
uh the audible like click of a shotgun
usually deters people wait wait how did
you get license and how did you order
this and how much was it and how do you
get bullets and have you shot one before
no and is is is vinny
fine with it then he's fine with it
vinnie wanted this okay so i have a safe
in my house now okay i put a safety
safe i got a safe and it's in the wall
and that's where that gun's going to be
okay start from the beginning where did
you get permitted so the permit is you
fill out just paperwork online and then
you have to go down was like devry yeah
it's like it's literally just for a
hunting license rifle you can get these
things in new york and then there's a
hunting like a uh i don't know if it's
nypd but it's like a licensing bureau
through the state of new york and one of
my neighbors
friends works for them so it's usually
you submit uh uh you know you submit the
paperwork or you know background check
or social security you have to do all
that stuff and then it takes months
because there's millions you know not
millions there's a lot of people so
you've been at this for months no first
you're mentioning no no because that's
why because i know somebody in the
office my
uh uh uh uh application was pushed to
the top
so i now
i filled out the paperwork last week but
i was told by my friend your application
no have you ever held one no but i'm
good have you ever loaded one zero have
you ever seen one in the front of your
eyes no okay yeah license yes
there's no test you have to there's no
test you have to pass
when do you wait wait a second wait a
second first of all don't you hunt a
buck with like i have buck hunter
downstairs
don't you have don't you want to buck
with like a like a like a proper you
when you're hunting bucks you're just
spraying bullets everywhere yeah i think
so it's a shooting shot yeah so then you
don't need to worry about your aim well
no because it's the same thing like when
you get a boating license you don't have
to prove that you can drive a boat you
can get a boating license with a new
york state driver's license and then you
just hit the buck with the boat exactly
right yeah so so i'm gonna have to my
yeah my yeah my buck shot shotgun on the
boat so what is it how big is it what
does it look like i genuinely have no
idea should we go to the gun range do
you want to go to the gun range babe's
date the gun right is there a gun range
yeah on staten island in new jersey too
really yeah there's a gun range that you
could shoot i've gone to i've gone twice
in my life have you done a shotgun they
kind of hurt i believe that i did once
yeah yeah it's it's a little ner it's
nerve-wracking you should break this
dude i was with um bert kreischer uh
yesterday um and he bought just recently
bought an ak-47 oh good
so he has an ak-47
how could he have that
you can legally buy it he had it in his
property
why would he talk i was on two bears one
cave and he just he's openly talking
about his ak-47 that he then proceeded
to show me after the show
why does he need that
for bucks for bucks
man bucks better look out well that's
the thing is because you guys want to
keep attacking comedians on stage so now
now they're fighting back right we're
looking at you as bucks now do you know
the guy who attacked dave chappelle on
stage he tied on he had a knife
taped to his gun it was like he had a
bayonet he had a gun he had a knife he
had a knife he had a knife
he had a gun shaped knife yes it was a
gun right that had a knife inside of it
or something yes and what was he going
to do it does anyone know why he
attacked him no lunatic luna oh well
first of all he talked about
allegedly so you know what i found out
is that he actually had nothing to do
with a joke or not bridge with a joke no
it was like he wanted to raise awareness
for homelessness no yeah it was like
some weird thing
well but i found out that that word
didn't really get out rihanna was in the
front row of that show and the show had
ended and rihanna's security team
somehow got separated from rihanna and
rihanna being pregnant some like fan i
think like ran up towards rihanna and
not in like a weird lot like to hurt her
but like just get a picture and rihanna
like want to cover her belly because
she's pregnant and dave chappelle
security guard that was blocking that
entrance jumped down from the stage and
tried to protect rihanna and that guy
snuck up so there's a conspiracy that
it's all they were all in cahoots
wow i didn't hear any of that this is
the weapon here
yeah yeah what is what is that he
probably made that on one of those
printers 3d printers it's so hard for me
to get my camera into these events how
did this get in yeah how did especially
at a chappelle show he usually has i
mean he takes your phone away but he
usually has uh
does he have metal detectors and [ __ ]
well yeah dude i was at the castle now i
was at the comedy store the next night
after the attack and you know you can
normally like walk freely through the
comedy store in los angeles but he was
performing there up in the belly room
yeah there was a wall of security that
even comics who are comedy store
regulars who free roam could not walk
past these security guards like you
cannot get anywhere near him what is the
point of a gun
a knife at the end of a gun
it's
internet it's stupid
but a bayonet was long it doesn't even
make sense like it's a handgun so it's
not even practical to use the knife it's
also made of plastic
that's plastic yeah so i was saying he
probably made that off a 3d printer he
could have right so this person was a
ghost was this person not all there yeah
yeah he's completely it's fantastic
mental health issues so he sat through
two-hour chapelle show laughing yeah
laughing at everything and then at the
end was like all right i'm going to take
my gun knife and i'm just going to raise
awareness for homelessness and by the
way did you see his arm he looked like a
cartoon yeah i know they look like a
cartoon like thompson and i i know he
did i heard that that was done after the
fact to like send a message like that
wasn't like like security was like i'm
gonna break your [ __ ] arms he got
stomped out by jamie foxx and busta
rhymes jamie foxx and buster ryan were
stomping him out wow i haven't seen
scott i haven't seen busta rhymes stop
anyone out since school talks by the way
i just want to say
i believe
gangster's paradise what was what was
what was that thing with oh would with
that that that leo no
no the movie with like michael rappaport
where they like oh yeah when he plays
like a shooter i'm like a nutshell oh
yeah and buster rhymes
who stomp somebody in that isn't that i
don't know i i oh higher learning yeah
yeah um uh i think jamie foxx is the
most talented uh entertainer we have in
the world in the world yeah i think he's
the most talented person we have so he
is a personally i think he's a singer
a rapper i guess a
singer yeah a singer
a singer an actor yeah
uh a comedian yep a fantastic comedian
yeah that barely does stand up he's a
fantastic and he's a great actor great
actor ray charles and all that other
stuff i haven't seen him in a minute
though
he also looks pretty young for his age
right yeah yeah
who knows jamie foxx who knows how old
jamie foxx he might be the oldest man in
the world might be
baby boy yep i've been there you've been
there it could be hard uh when you have
some high interest debt
and you can't feel like you can dig your
way out of it it's hard to ask for help
right that's where something like
upstart comes in babe i want to find a
way to say baby
it's a high interest credit card debt
that's what i want to say goodbye to
because it's one of the first steps
towards financial independence yes but
the interest month at the month could
feel like
you feel like you're never gonna get out
dude i feel like never gonna get out
it's it's emotionally draining it's it's
it's physically like a hamster wheel
it's like a i literally feel like i'm in
a hamster and the only way to get off
that hamster wheel is to go through
upstart upstart powered personal loans
can help you pay down high interest debt
online with simple and easy on to
understand payment terms uh they know
you're more than just a credit score so
rather than looking at just your credit
score what they do is their their model
consists of other factors like your
income employment and other information
provided in your loan application and
you could check your rate in minutes for
loans between 1 000 to 50 000 without
impacting credit score that's big 50
bans yes baby you can even receive funds
as fast as one business they have to
accept the loan don't wait and check out
your rate today at upstart.com hey babe
that's
upstart.com
hey babe to check your rate today don't
forget to use our url to let them know
we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information providing
your loan application go to upstart.com
all right this podcast is sponsored by
better help help baby we use better help
we love better help we talk about better
health here on a weekly basis we're all
about mental health and get your mental
health right i want you to get right
with god and i want you to get right
with your mental health that is true
yeah no true words ever been spoken yes
uh i have been overwhelmed lately
particularly hundreds i'm filming we are
drinking
with sharks i'm moving i was swimming
with sharks shout out shark week yeah um
i get burned out dude many people do it
of course uh and i just overworked and i
need to feel some type of relief what
better help does what i love about
better help is it's it's guidance
counselors it's like it's it's all on
zoom they're online therapists online
i'd say online therapists that guide you
um it's all on zoom it's all um done
from the comfort of your own home
they're professionals and it really just
helped and better help is customized
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat sessions with your
therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
babe it's more affordable than in-person
therapy which by the way i also do and
that is an arm and a leg and my
insurance only covers 70 of it yes and
you can match up with a therapist under
48 hours right because i was going to uh
therapy to uh you know in-person therapy
too and my therapist's breath smelled
like [ __ ] so that's why i better help
that's a pitfall you know it avoids that
too if you if if you're you won't smell
that [ __ ] breath if you're if your
therapist got breath that's hot as ass
then it doesn't matter if they're with
you with better help you can eliminate
that also i was always a little bit
afraid to reach out and go to a
therapist i didn't know they were gonna
be good or bad or not this is so much
easier direct less committal and you
could dip a toe by doing it this way no
literally because i used to have another
therapist that every time during our
session for whatever reason he would eat
full eggs he would just eat scrambled
eggs and he would make them while we
were talking and now if the therapist i
would smell that and i would be like why
are you eating old scrambled eggs all
day and now if your therapist is doing
that you can just simply be like hey i'd
rather go to to better help because if
therapists want to eat scrambled eggs i
can eat them all day because i ain't
smelling it through my computer no
you're not child hey babe listeners get
10 percent out their first month at
betterhelp.com hey babe that's
betterhelp betterhelp.com
um speak dude now let me ask you a
question nasa two things one there's
about to be a hotel in space by 2025 no
are you gonna go but what if they marry
a pawn boy
[Laughter]
if i could use points i might get those
points who's gonna go stay beautiful
that's what it is yeah it actually looks
pretty dope nah nah not for you but how
is it suspended up there it's just going
around the earth's gravitational uh no
like not no it's going to be a floating
pod yeah i think that it's going i think
that it's going around like how like a
satellite goes around
no you're not do you think you'd be able
to
but you got to build it on the ground
right yeah so they have to launch it up
build it and launch it up i think only a
few hundred that's it it looks like it
looks like a it looks like a tractor
tire i was listening
that's what it is it does look like why
do i need to go up there i don't want to
do it to
to eat to eat food and watch tv why yeah
i'll go what do you do at a hotel for
the grand bro for the that's it it is
all for the grand the graham can kiss my
ass
the gram
i think i think that um the cram i care
about truly is graham crackers that's
true graham cracker yeah i don't care
graham crackers what about graham norton
what about graham hancock who talks
about i don't know graham hancock look
into him i care about graham hancock
graham norton i i wonder if i will do a
show when i one day you go if you go to
still do that yeah yes
graham graham cracker is unsung it's
basic it's a basic [ __ ] but it's been
around forever for a reason what about
honey grams i love it
oh you mean the cereal yeah i like them
a lot but they're not like graham
crackers you know what about teddy grams
oh yeah i love teddy graham city grams
are good but they got to get a new
flavor though they got honey they got
chocolate love them both cinnamon decent
chocolate chip chocolate they're not
the chocolate ones is what i
consistently ate for cereal as a child
growing up that's why i would pour the
teddy graham chocolate telegrams into
milk and eat that as cereal no parent
around
i would do that religiously no that's
what my mother would give me for
breakfast did she think it was a cereal
cause it kind of looks like cereal yeah
no she i maybe we created oh do you know
what i did i went out to uh breakfast
yesterday and do you know what i
did i took i asked for a toasted
blueberry muffin with butter and the
butter was melted in and you know what i
did and i feel like i created this i had
there was maple syrup on the table i cut
this muffin open and i poured maple
syrup on the muffin and they ate a
blueberry muffin toasted butter with
maple syrup added to the mice and did
you ejaculate it first of all i couldn't
see for about an hour but
it was
the best thing i think i've ever in in
my entire life a blueberry muffin is one
of the best things to ever ever be in
blueberry muffin toasted butter is so
good that many times i order it i go to
take a bite and it's so good that i want
to throw the rest of the muffin off the
wall you just want to i just want to get
the
kids
yeah i want to throw it at the waitress
i think blooms is better than even
chocolate chip i think blueberries is
the best muffin
wow i do blueberry you know what i've
never not bitten to a blueberry muffin
and been like i don't want to be
anywhere but here right now yeah right
how come there's not raspberry muffins
cranberry muffins cronberry i think
[ __ ] those berries
they're like talk too [ __ ] and well i
think a bad blueberry can be bad too
though yeah that's true yeah but you
know what a cranberry
if it's not in a drink which is just
straight up it's not great you ever see
those ocean spray commercials with how
they get cranberries it's like a it's
like a river of cranberries
like that's how they get cranberries
they don't grow off trees they just
float in water no go to go to ocean
spray cranberry but that's just is that
cranberry is that just the uh
is that the
through water to get cranberries
what go to how do you get cranberry
mining for cranberries ocean spray
cranberry commercial maybe also i've
been totally thinking of raspberries
this whole time there's no i've never
seen a raspberry about
cranberries regular right you don't just
pop cranberries they're too
you can't eat just cranberries
look it
see what's just a river of cranberries
that's what cranberries i don't know
dude that's right there this this is
this is how this is how you stop a uti
the only way you got it oh that's a body
of cranberry that's a body of
cranberries if you got a uti go jump in
that water
this is allison carr sixth generation
oh in
massachusetts they're harvested in water
yep
isn't that wild
that's a cranberry they harvest that is
the craziest thing i've ever seen yeah
this is how they get cranberries i don't
think that you can get them any other
way oh or do they knock them off the
vines and put them in the water
uh
i don't know
i don't know but it's wild right it is
like i've never seen i've never seen
that like bananas on trees they are so
you could have a banana tree in your
house
i think you have the right climate for
it but yeah
interesting i want to have trees like uh
fruit trees when i get home but what
fruit trees can you really grow in new
york i don't really know i don't think
you can i don't think our climate whack
as [ __ ] otherwise if i could
if i could i'd do lemon orange cherry i
believe interesting that's what i would
do i think you could grow avocado no you
can't grow avocado there's cartels now
avocados and limes cocktail is taking it
over like it's cocaine i know i don't
brought to that but what diamonds let me
tell you something i've been watching i
watch it on the plane i haven't um
finished gone to the third episode yet
baby girl
there's a documentary about do you know
about three mile island never a child
you know about three mile island pimp no
is this the nuclear power plant bro
three mile island is the united states
chernobyl that nobody talks about
what are you talking about
nuclear radiation coming out the ass
since 1979 and these [ __ ] don't
want to talk about it now there's a good
there's this there's a conspiracy theory
on long island that this is where lyme
disease came from it's three mile island
yeah uh uh there also is another
conspiracy this is where autism could
have come from there's a lot of
conspiracies around
the three-mile island accident have you
just heard of this sugar baby uh yeah
baby girl it's on netflix you know what
else on netflix especially where she my
comedy special
is it still trending it's still trending
keep it trending uh review it right or
rate it yeah uh uh you can netflix now
has a thing where you could give it a
thumbs up one thumbs up is like it two
thumbs up is love it really so i would
love it love special weshy
i have not seen it
on netflix i saw it when you sent it i
was going to talk to you about that
because about anything you were choosing
between
nycc and that and all that stuff and you
just went full i went full i put the
special on netflix is is called
specially weshy but there will be
another special that i'm going to be
releasing on my youtube called
youtube.com christy comedy and then yet
a third cut that we're going to be
putting only at patreon.com says christy
comedy so your boy chrissy content is
trying to give the people what they
haven't asked for which is more content
right so you're gonna just release
everything yeah yeah i'm gonna release
everything i have and then also i did
yesterday i was at the netflix as a joke
comedy festival shout out netflix i did
um amy schumer and friends had uh she
has a show coming out on netflix where
like she hosts and then five comics do
stand up did she book you or there's
just someone uh i i think she did yeah
and then i
absolutely bombed on both tapings so
there's no escaping two tapings so when
you've seen both tapings same stuff both
how many minutes
seven minutes babe seven minutes is
tough
here's the thing it was a show about the
theme was parenting okay and family and
i went up first on both shows but the
theme was family and you got that on
lockdown i proceeded to do instead
because i just done all my family jokes
on special western netflix i had not a
lot of new material so i proceeded on a
family show that amy schumer did jokes
about family great jokes about her
family i proceeded to do a six-minute
bit about how my dog larry died and now
he was given the wrong medication i love
that show talked about hey babe and it
the only way that joke works is if you
laugh at the beginning then there's a
little bit of setup you laugh a little
bit in the middle and then a huge blast
at the end
and none of that happened nobody laughed
in the middle they kind of laughed a
little bit in the uh nobody left in the
beginning
subtle laughs in the middle and then the
end was a full cricket bomb no full
qriket bomb the first show i just got
off and was like whatever i have to do
the second show i hit the punch line
which normally gets laughs absolutely
bombed i look straight into the camera i
said i'm going to kill myself
i swear to god
laughing in the hallway back he goes i
can't believe you said that he goes if
netflix has any balls they'll keep that
in i said well they do have balls
because in my special especially
at the end of the netflix i say i'm
putting this whole thing on youtube [ __ ]
[ __ ] everybody but if netflix wants to
buy it i'll sell it to you and they let
me keep that in the special that's cool
that's cool but this one i looked direct
devon cameron said i'm gonna kill myself
what other comics were
did every did i love people bomb was it
the crowd um uh james mcbride did very
well
the space was at this place called the
palladium you know the palladium okay
it's like a music venue yeah um and they
had chairs set up i think what happened
was this one my new jokes aren't very
funny two is um um
they
papered the audience meaning like nobody
sold tickets to this this was just like
in los angeles everyone wants to be an
actor
they were like thought they were like
how do they not know better
i don't know if it was necessarily i
don't know i actually don't know why it
happened that way but i for sure nobody
came off and said they had a good is jay
mcbride killed both shows give i'll give
you props on that shout out jamie pride
um but nobody commented on like how bad
the crowds were um i mean we all
commented on how bad the crowds were but
nobody took it harder than me i mean i
cuz i think going on first just ate a
nice fat [ __ ] right in the face um
but it is interesting because i think go
ahead get in there um um
nice careers popping babe you read that
well is it fun can you can you
flex and just pop things
it's hot like it's stuck to my skin yeah
yeah
you could probably take a nice spill
down the steps and get right back up i
think i'd be fine honestly to be honest
with you i feel like a nice painting
yeah that's what i feel like yeah i feel
like a genuine nice painting just go
home and that and don't say anything see
what they say walk right into just one
family don't say a word well i have to
take delilah to a birthday party so i
might as well just show up like this
yeah just show up yeah yeah when they're
like what are you doing did you just be
like there was turbulence um yeah babe
you know it's one of those things where
the thing is with stand up when you you
know we don't talk about stand up that
much on the show but when you do stand
up talk stand up speak stand up baby
it's just it's it's difficult sometimes
to turn over new material quickly on a t
th here's the thing with the tv takes
taping seven minutes with a paper
audience not good if it was just a seven
minute set i wouldn't have done those
jokes a and b i would have just done
crowd work done a bunch of [ __ ] uh and
then i i i also didn't realize that
one on the first set i did i did a whole
i did the the the larry dying joke and
then i did it two minutes of just
[ __ ] on portland for no reason just
[ __ ] on portland and the great you
preconceived this or you were just
flying by the city of panama no no these
are the jokes that were approved by
netflix okay um and then i didn't
realize that the comedian going after me
the the great ron funches ron functions
another great friend of the show is from
portland and had about 80 people there
to see him at the show so
so i never met ronnie ron's a great guy
yeah he was two weeks ago he's got a two
week old baby yeah peripherally i know
he likes wrestling and stuff like that
and so but uh yeah so speaking of stand
up it's the 12th in two days i will be
at the beacon theater
new york city new york city in two days
from now and then uh you said i like
21st i'll be in san diego and the 22nd
i'll be at the wiltern in l.a dude the
will turn i drove past it nice venue a
lot there's um the la now is starting to
get a little bit
uh uh better just shadier uh where i was
i was staying at the w in in hollywood
so fine was kind of like a war zone
where is the wilton theater the wilton
theater i heard it's like a beacon
theater it's beautiful
i drove past just the sign i don't know
what like i don't know la it was some
you know it's a big theater i i mean i'm
trying to sell that out los angeles sell
it out
it's just in a week and a half after
will turn wilton 22nd um
uh so your trip to there was good my
trip there was good i just come off the
plane i flew i got on a 6 a.m flight
this morning landed here came right
straight right to you um you know the
taping the taping the amy schumer taping
ended last night at 1am that i was
picked up at three
tough baby girl tough baby girl shout
out to amy schumer if you're watching
and we know that you are we know that
you are shout out to me babe roll back
first of all if you've seen pictures of
me lately i'm wearing roll back once you
look good thank you
i've been wearing roback is a company
they got performance hoodies performance
polos performance q-zips the performance
hoodie is the best
activewear right it's active where it's
the best article of clothing i've ever
bought in my life no it's fit best field
they sent me packages of it and then i
went and used our promo code and i
bought more hundreds of dollars worth of
this merch no i'm like people are making
me it looked amazing they sent me the
wrong size i gave them to my dad he's
over the moon about it no it literally
is i'm telling you i for summer for
spring or every all seasons i'm wearing
robot i wore rollback on the on the um
on the on the netflix taping i bombed no
i roll back on
i like the little dog logo it's the best
they are gaining a lot of traction so uh
of course you guys are going to get a
deal right always you get a deal
use the code babe on rollback.com for a
generous 20 off your first order through
the end of this week that's spelled roll
back it's r h o
b a c k dot com twenty percent off all
polos q zips hoodies tees with the code
babe make sure to check out their
freshly restocked hoodies and new
masters gear just in time for the spring
hello fresh baby what is it it's
america's number one meal kid what it is
thank you for sponsoring this podcast uh
with hellofresh what do you do you get
farm fresh pre-portioned ingredients and
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
doorstep skip trips to the grocery store
and count on hello fresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable and you
know what i did last week you know
sunday was mother's day would you pass
hello fresh i made the lemon regatta
pancakes and the french macarons that
they have bro
unbelievable my mother enjoyed those
pancakes so much she got up she said i
don't even want to be your mama no more
whoa
that doesn't track
yeah why would she get upset
by the way you said macarons yes and
i always thought it was macaroons but i
found out last night it was macarons oh
really said it correctly look at that
yeah i didn't know but i will tell you
this we even cooked hellofresh if you
watch the no press doc which is edited
beautifully and directed by the homeless
pimp yes a lot of fun we actually did a
hello fresh head on there where you and
i cooked a meal yes and it was fantastic
and hello fresh is truthfully it's
something that's become a part of my
life it's part of sal's life um
we love it i love to cook with it i i
would say i eat hello fresh for 90 of my
meals per week that is more than me but
i do eat it at least twice a week hello
fresh has fit and wholesome recipes for
satisfying and nutritious meals you can
feel good about with six recipes to
choose from per week including low
calorie and carb conscious options you
can change what you what you order you
could stop at any time you could do all
that jazz you do all that jazz and if
you go to hellofresh.com
hey babe16 and use the code hey babe 16
you're going to get 16 free meals plus
three free gifts it's literally like
they're giving the food away for free
that's hellofresh.com hey babe 16 and
use code hey babe 16 for up to 16 free
meals what are the gifts
i mean if you've
done this
in the comments let us know what gifts
you're reading that's always a gift song
i'm telling you what the gift is
mysterious the lemon regatta pancakes
could be the gift
um i or i was dude did really good on my
diet um until two nights ago um i just
was up uh i was exhausted i i i was like
i'm not drinking and everything la
everything closes early the only thing
that was open dominoes okay dominoes so
i went to domino's i went in
okay we got um banana peppers mushroom
medium pizza uh we got breadsticks we
got sweet
uh me and you can't have them oh it's
just me
it actually was just me
yeah and then we got the brownie
unfortunately oh i don't know i never
had that was that the oreo cookie thing
uh
no it's a
like just a standard brownie in a tray
dude you can't find anything no and i
gotta die at fonta
i don't even know that i got to diet oh
yeah i came while you were there i was
in the bahamas hosting shark week oh my
god i want to talk about this shark week
yeah it's pretty wild but i ate terrible
would you i ate everything bro i i
didn't eat bad at
no i didn't eat too bad actually but i
did eat bad but let me tell you
something you have to go to bahamas yes
i have okay i stayed shattered
sat on horseshoe bay uh i stayed at
atlantis years and years and years ago i
found the lost city of atlanta i found
it i stayed there and you know like
eight nine years ago it was pretty good
but i stayed at baja mar okay this time
so they are a huge property with three
hotels on it competing with atlantis
right and they have the hyatt the grand
hyatt the sls which is like a w like a
party hotel and then they had the
rosewood which was obscenely priced i
gotta tell you i gotta just say this
baja mar if you're listening and we know
that you are
you got to do something about your
prices and this is coming from someone
who is still single with no children and
has saved money right but dude i ordered
at the pool i ordered a
uh it was called a gingersnap okay it
was casamigos tequila with some ginger
beer and a little bit of mint sounds
actually good and i ordered a seltzer
okay
52. what 52. so
apparently i asked i said can you just
put a double shot in there so it was a
double shot but that was it was one
drink and one seltzer is 52 that's too
much and they charge you a tax for
bahamas then they charge you a 15
service tax not for the person to give
you the drink but for this but staff
altogether and then that person makes it
a point to tell you i don't get anything
out of either the bahama tax or the
bahama tax and so if you want to tip me
you got to tip on top of that so then i
got a tip on top of the 52 i took five
on top of it for the drink so it was 57
and i walked back and i swear to god oh
so what happened was he poured he poured
the drink i said
is this good so after he made the drink
he slides it over he goes taste it see
if you like it so i went to taste it i
sipped it i couldn't taste tequila at
all right there was like no together i
just tasted like sweet ginger beer i was
gonna say you could taste no you didn't
have covert no no okay it could he put
nothing in okay barely nothing in there
so i didn't want to insult him so he
goes how is it and i go nah it's good
it's good i go you know what i go uh
this way i don't have to come all the
way back here i said throw another shot
in there yeah and uh just because i'm
like i can't taste it so he drops the
check it says 52 dollars right and this
is before he gives me the second shot
so i'm looking at i'm like are you
[ __ ] kidding me so i tip five dollars
and he comes over and he looks down to
get the check i know that he looked down
and saw the tip that i tipped on top of
the ship and i know that he knows that
it was 52
i asked him to i tasted it and then i
asked him and then he wrung up the check
for the both and then he didn't pour the
drink yet and i signed it and he looked
and i was like all right maybe this guy
is going to give me a heavy pour on this
one because it's clear why i ordered a
second one right and he knows he's
getting me for the price of a bottle of
gas amigos right on one drink and the
guy
opened the thing and he poured out i was
a bartender for a decade right he poured
out less than another ounce of alcohol
wow and i'm not the guy that's going to
be online being like because i used to
bartend and people would be like yo let
me get this and i would make it then
they they already had it predetermined
they were going to be like it's not
strong enough
right they were there was people that
would do that all the time they'd be
like no you got to put more liquor in
there because i just want more because
they just want more and i know how to
bartend right and i'd be like no no
that's what it's supposed to be if they
weren't if they were a dick that's what
it's supposed to be if you want another
one you got to pay for another one i
wouldn't take no not take that [ __ ]
but i'm not gonna be that guy to him
yeah and so i just walked away yeah with
a
even with his second shot i couldn't
taste it and i sat down and i literally
just cursed for like five minutes on
vacation i'm like 57 i feel
i feel like
i feel terrible this is terrible they
gossip down there because i stayed at
the same spot and i kept asking the
bartenders who's the worst tip or famous
person no [ __ ]
yeah but five dollars is a good enough
tip on a drink i mean if there was 52
dollars already i was actually confused
about everything because i didn't find
out that you didn't i thought that i
kept on doing this i kept on putting
additional because there's a line for
tip right but it says
that tax and then it says service charge
tax for the hotel and that's 15
and i'm always like i hate when a server
i get it when they have to do it for
parties of over six or eight because
they don't want to get ripped off a
server they want to make sure they get
at least something but i do so i get it
but when they put it on when i'm dining
with like a person right and they put it
on i'm like you screwed yourself like
why do that because i would have gave
you i tip like 30 to 50 you know what i
mean so if you don't know so sometimes
i'm like
i'll just give you what you asked for
then like you know what i mean so was
dinner just like six thousand dollars
dude for like we had we had one we had
one dinner for um
uh for someone's birthday there and it
was like
damn
there was like 15 people at the time oh
my god
all ordering drinks five grand yep five
thousand yes it was did you get hit with
the bill yeah we split it oh you split
it okay no i mean i mean we split it
with two i swear with two people was
that on resort
yeah because the off resort gets even
crazier yeah resort is i thought officer
would be less money it was forty five
hundred dollars a plus i added more so
i'm looking at the fifteen percent rent
and that's when i found that i'm like
well fifty percent of four forty five
hundred dollars is a lot of money kind
of so i was like but i'll put additional
so i would put additional like 150 or
whatever like right and i'm thinking
it's additional meanwhile it's really
just 150 i found out after the fact
because they like split the 15 with all
the staff so they really know how to get
you but i would go eat a meal i swear to
god dude i went to him i went to a
italian restaurant on the premises
it says chicken parmesan i said
does it come on anything they said no
it's just a cutlet
with sauce and cheese there's no pasta
or nothing with it a salad nothing like
bread no nothing i said all right that
was one of the things i ordered she goes
i go how big is it she goes it's a four
ounce breast oh my god i said and i go
four ounces four to six ounce she
brought it i ordered
it was a chicken cutlet that big with
sauce and cheese on it and it was like
the plate dwarfed it do you know how
much that chicken parmesan was honestly
with what you've been saying 35 no 50.
no
56 no yes it was and it was a chicken
cutlet that big i would have meals every
day there that here the meal would be
about 60
60 total all in the meals were four
hundred dollars for a sixty dollar meal
here four hundred dollars
why are people even going bahamut i had
a side of pasta with that and then we
got like
mozzarella for the table and like a
salad and i had did i have a drink
i had one glass of wine and the bill
between the bill between four people was
471 okay so here's the thing with me
though like with the bahamas place like
that right yeah so you hear that you
know like now it's like i wouldn't how
could a family go there exactly because
it's like and also like let's say you
know you're [ __ ] all y'all if you're
watching bahamas i know
and by the way [ __ ] the bomber since day
one you know bahamas is nasty day one
[ __ ] you nassau bahamas you know what
that was now obama's that's the that was
the uh all got started that was the uh
where pirates that's like the original
pirate capital like blackbeard and real
or like famous pirates was not the
nassau bahamas was where all the pirates
that was like the capital a pi there's a
great netflix show called uh lost pirate
kingdom and it's all about and it was
all there all nassau so they've been
pirating is that one is that lord
are there like chests with treasures in
it or is that lore no no uh what
happened was so what with pirating what
really what happened was is is that when
it all got started
spain you know like the invincible
armada that spain used they used to rule
the seas they were ruling the seas the
seven seas and their spanish uh armada
which was the best fighting force for
like a hundred years
um started to lose a lot of their uh
ships from shipwrecks because bermuda
triangle stuff for all the hurricanes
and all that stuff because they when
they would come from a lot of sunken
ships i scuba dived to them well that's
why you did and puerto rico that's why
puerto rico became so important the rich
port because spain would come from uh
spain and they would stop at puerto rico
you know that was a beautiful island it
was like halfway point or whatever they
would stop and like rest and all that
and then when they would go on to the
bahamas go on to florida whatever a lot
of their ships would wreck and the
nassau bahamas there was a famous storm
i forgot what year it was where like
40
um uh katrina
hurricane yep
40 uh
ships from spain shipwrecked and like
had like millions and millions and
millions of dollars worth of gold and
that's when
that's crazy stay cold stay gold stay
right there babe stay gold this is back
to tulsa i'll tell you about that so so
that's yeah so so 1.6 billion a large
spanish galleon that sank in 1656 yep
they said they found they found it so
they were looking for black beard and
all those guys were looking for this 400
year old shipwreck that was full of gold
silver emeralds and artifacts estimated
at 1.6 billion in the bahamas
well let me tell you you're going to
need that to have dinner there exactly
you're going to need that but i was
furious no i but i'm talking about like
with oham is like like if you're from
the us right why not then just go to
florida i know like what's the
difference seriously between the bombs
in florida seriously what's the
difference well is the bahamas beaches
are that much nicer than beaches in
florida don't well well i think some of
them are i think some of them are i
don't know much of florida but isn't
florida just standard like waves hitting
the beach and not like pure tropical
solace
because there's p this place is in this
place
because this place in the muhammad like
next to no waves that is crystal crystal
blue like i took a boat out every day we
were on the boat i was in the high seas
every day that's why i had no service i
was eight what i want to know about not
the tipping what were the sharks like
what the hell happened sharks was crazy
okay so you would just go out and find
sharks and they had like no we had a
whole thing we had to do this whole
hour-long episode uh it was me qmr right
we had to go out there and host this
whole week and we all did shark dives
dolphin dives and we also got to do some
of our bits out there and then we also
like wrote our own storylines you guys
prank sharks
yo i prank i i i got into a kids yeah i
prank kids
great i bring kids big i i did a whole
thing so we had these three story lines
so the storyline was that discovery gave
us this big budget and we could use it
any way we want that's true though right
and so q decided that he was going to
hunt for the staten island red devil
shark this shark he saw as a kid and so
he actually got certified it was i mean
all joking you know but he got certified
as a scuba instructor before we went
there i couldn't end up the time so when
we went there he did a 60-foot dive to a
to an abandoned ship amongst dozens of
sharks
like like out in the open shower in the
open
how is that safe
because they are trained to not attack
you and he went down with divers and
they had sticks in case the sharks came
to poke the sharks in the nose and he he
went down and he didn't have gloves on
and apparently at one point they were
throwing chum out so the sharks would go
around him and he like was lost his
balance and he had his hand behind his
back and a shark started to go at his
hand and this guy shout out doc doctor
craig shout out dr chris craig is on
shark week every year with the
celebrities at host it was like that
well it wasn't that many sharks but it
was like that
it was like it was they were like uh
reef sharks oh god yeah yeah yeah like
that that's what they were doing and the
shark started to charge at his hand to
bite it and dr craig saw it the last
second and shoot the shark away and it
was going like this and it went right
away from his hand and he didn't tell us
that till the last day
but he was supposed to be he would have
bitten q's hand off possibly yeah
apparently jackass hosted it a couple of
years ago and this guy poop poop poopy
poop yeah shut up poop
poopy he
like wakeboarded off a ramp or something
and landed on sharks and they bit his
hand off and it was swinging off his arm
and they like they wanted to get bit but
it bit him that bad oh my god and they
had to rush him out of that out of there
they said his hand was hanging off
but anyway but you guys could do some
great pranks if you only had one
so so q did all this stuff he did this
dive and then murr wanted to speak to
dolphins and decode dolphin language so
he had all this equipment he bought and
he did a dive with dolphins and then he
wanted to speak to dolphins so he could
learn dolphin language to talk to the
sharks and tell the sharks to stop
attacking us these were all like sketch
sketches you know and then me
i
was afraid of sharks and didn't want to
do any of it right so i didn't
so i i bought i took the whole budget
and bought a diamond watch so i have a
full pete like cat dj khaled p diddy
like a hundred percent diamond encrusted
glistening watch the entire episode on
and i'm just like yeah i didn't
i don't want to really talk about how i
spent my uh
is this a crossover is it your format or
their no it's their format but we did do
two of our bits we we like almost like
in the movie like we we
weaved them into the actual storyline
right and uh and then and then so i had
to meet with kids so my my whole thing
was i was afraid to dive with the sharks
so first i was going to go to the kid to
the uh nurse sharks which are like
they're still six feet but they like
supposedly don't bite they suck right
but they said they're hot nurses they
could suck your arm right now i was like
good
[Music]
exactly
so so i'm talking to kids suck off yeah
so i'm talking to the kids it's
ridiculous they don't know like they
just their parents volunteered them but
they're thinking they're sorry they're
local bohemian children they are but
they're not necessarily just
being natives there anyone and everyone
who just lives there now and so the
parents signed them up to go with the
nurse sharks so they had no idea so i'm
down by the nurse sharks alone and then
the kids would come down to this lagoon
and it was just me and the kids and then
i they had long lens hidden cameras and
i would just [ __ ] with the kids for
like an hour i talked to like 10
different kids
ridiculous stuff ridiculous and it was
really funny and then in the end all the
kids did the lagoon dive with me with
these nurse sharks and the shark there
was seven of them and we were in like
thigh high lit uh high water and these
sharks were just circling us dude and
the guy was throwing chum and they'd
come and they'd suck it up are you
nervous truthfully truthfully like were
you nervous truthfully i was [ __ ] my
pants
there was one point where i didn't give
[ __ ] i took every kid and i i grabbed
them by their vests because they were
wearing life vests i wasn't i put my arm
through their vests and i was holding
the kids three kids like a shield and
every time and it gets started screaming
and crying i didn't even care every time
a shark would come near us i would turn
the kids and they'd be like nah and
we're like
just calm down it's all right it's all
right another shot and i had to on my
own like
a goddamn human shield i was holding him
out like i wouldn't let the shark get
within two feet my arms length i was
holding the children out like it was a
hostage situation and the kids were like
no no
shut up just shut up it's gonna be fine
don't make a move it was scary hilarious
and then i ended up
getting on the third day we did dives
every day and we went out into the
middle of nowhere and the third day was
really really rough waters okay so i
took the medicine we had medics on there
we had a shout out to the whole crew
they were amazing
these guys are in the rough waters
filming they go down
in their scuba gear with these big
cameras these huge cameras they hold
like this and uh anyway i i never got
seasick before i got seasick okay
throwing
oh you're fully puking
puking right so he made a jokes at the
beginning of the episode well like hey
we're here on shark it was like a drone
shot that was gonna introduce the
episode's gonna pull away and see us on
the islands and so we're like hey we're
here for shark week stay tuned it's
gonna be great and i had fake vomit in
my mouth and that was a joke we just
we're gonna do it so when the thing i
was like yeah they're like check it out
stay tuned i'm like what i threw up
everyone i'm like shark week and then it
just the thing went away and then i
guess i was foreshadowing because i was
throwing up the entire time and they
were recording it so i guess it's gonna
be on camera but they put me in the
shark cage i wasn't gonna go free
swimming with them but they put me in
the shark cage and in rough waters
though and it completely tore me up
ripped i banged up my legs i was
bleeding the thing was rocking like it
was an earth underwater underwater it
was rocking like it was an earthquake
i'm in the gear and everything i go down
and basically they were going to try and
dump this stuff that's going to attract
all the sharks to the cage and then they
want to test out a repellent to see if
this repellent worked so once they
dumped all and the sharks swarmed they
dumped this after a few minutes they
dumped this repellent it turned the
water bright green and to see and it
didn't repel them okay so i'm slamming
back and forth in this thing and i'm
already seasick i was seasick this
happened like hours in were you throwing
up in your scuba gear no as soon as i
got out of the cage and back on the boat
i lifted it up leaned over and threw up
everywhere wow and they had dead
rotting like fish
a station that they were slicing these
frozen fish they were called bonitas and
they were slicing them and they were raw
and smelly and bloody and they come for
the blood right and so it would that was
everywhere and so when i got out i was
smelling that and the boat was rocking i
just started throwing up everywhere but
i'm in the cage and the cage is rocking
me back and forth and i literally can't
get down because it's so rough so then i
come back up they put weights on me they
tie me up with weights so i could sink
down and i get to the bottom of the cage
and the sharks are coming and you know
i'm not that scared because i'm in the
tank i'm in the cage you know but
it's shaking so much i grabbed the cage
to like
keep myself down there and to stay down
and i grabbed the cage and i grabbed two
bars and i guess the water [ __ ] and i
just went
and i didn't know it was a door
to hold the whole cage open the whole
thing like like a window sill that thing
just went
and went to the top and the whole thing
was open with shots everywhere
i was like oh my god so i was like
trying to pull it down and i couldn't
get it down and i slammed it down again
and then a few minutes later it happened
to me again because like when you're
when you're getting hit back and forth
i'm just grabbing for the tank to steady
myself and you grab any pole in front of
you and it swung open again dude so what
they didn't come in thank god they said
if because if a shark would have went in
there
and then it like fell down me and the
shark would be the case for ourselves
and that wouldn't have been good so now
when you're looking into a shark's eyes
what does it feel like they look demonic
they look demonic truthfully they're
like little beady like gray dead eyes
like
like you feel dinosaur energy right yeah
yeah yes it feels like that yes and and
look i'm not here to give bad pr to
sharks sharks if you're watching and we
know that you are shout out sharks
shadow sharks i'm not trying to do that
to you all i'm not trying to get a bad
representation watch shark week because
it's fun and we're gonna it's coming on
july 10th of july 17th or something but
it was it was a really really really
good time but when i mean when the shark
door opened like that i mean could you
imagine getting stuck you know what's
crazy i don't even know if i signed the
waiver i oh i yeah i did i think i
signed my life away do you
were there any of them like great well
like if you if the shark was in attack
with you it wouldn't have killed you or
no it could hit an artery and kill you
yeah but it's not a great
right but dr craig who lives here in
montauk or on long island i'm going to
go with him this summer there's great
whites off the coast of long island and
he's going to take me to see great
whites i'm not gonna get in the water
with him he gets in the water with him
unclear i don't know maybe maybe not i
don't know we should have him on that's
awesome so yeah he was great so the cage
though
like
like there's not like there's no way
anything can really go wrong like in a
serious way with the cage like like how
deep in the water are you okay so
there's multiple cages the cage i was in
had an open top so they don't want to
lower it too much because then the shark
are just going to the top right but i
needed that because i'm claustrophobic
so they had originally built me a
special cage just for me and the cage
the cage
because they knew i was scared so they
wanted to get more out of it they built
a cage for me that they were gonna lower
15 feet
and the cage is like you get in and you
close it and it's just like really like
kind of the size of a little bigger than
your body
so it's not like a square cage like a
prison cell but like
like a smaller cage and instead of
having big bars like a prison it has
little little bars like grates so you
can't get your hands out but then on the
top they cut the whole top out and they
put a plexiglass window oh wow so that
there's nothing there like that and this
thing's on a stick and it's completely
closed and they could so then they could
lower down 15 feet so that's what they
built for me so i'm out there and the
thing's rocking back and forth i'm
throwing up and i'm getting sick and
they go we're gonna put you in this
thing and they didn't tell me they made
a special cage just for me and then they
showed it to me and i go i can't go in
that and like why i'm like i'm
completely claustrophobic like
if you're gonna lock me in that little
cage and put me 15 feet down not only
can i not get out of the cage but i
can't get out to breathe either in water
i said i don't want to go down there and
then ruin this whole shoot for you
because if i get down there and i can't
take it you're going to pull me right
back up and it's going to get effed so
murray switched with me and he went in
that cage and then i got in the cage
that had the top still open so mine
still stayed relatively near the top of
the wall well that's my next question is
could you communicate with them somehow
if you were like i can't do this anymore
even in the other cage uh you need to
pull me up is there any way or you can't
okay so
in in past lives i i went scuba diving
once in grand cayman and they were just
talking about signals that you would do
like if you're okay if you're not if you
listen to that and those don't work
anyway by the way because i had one
instructor and me and my friend only two
people with one instructor it was almost
like a private lesson and she's like do
this if you can't this if you she's
telling me all these hand motions and
she goes all right let's go and we went
down 30 feet and she was ahead and then
my friend and then me and we were
trailing her and i there was like five
times i needed her and i'm [ __ ]
single but she just her back is to me
and she's just going forward like trying
to tell her i'm [ __ ] stuck i'm yeah i
look like i'm doing the macarena and
yeah and she's not even looking and i'm
like what good are the signals if you're
just going you're 20 feet ahead of me
going straight
anyway
i said that to them on this and they go
no we have the technology now you wear
this mask it's almost like an astronaut
mask
and your nose and mouth are free in it
and there's a button on the side of it
you push that has an intercom that talks
to the people upstairs and the other
divers so i was like what so we could
talk underwater they go yes so i go all
right went down we all did it we all did
our dies all went down
it never freaking worked they had to
come no like you they would you would
hear me i was trying to talk and i'm
trying to talk back to me but it was
like barely hearing it could barely hear
it was like staticky it was cutting out
and i know we never understood each
other at any given moment by the way uh
you're you've been on multiple cages in
different shows
i was on a bear cage barricade with the
grizzlies the cage with the zombies you
stay in cages
[Laughter]
yeah right but what what i feel like all
those cages but what we don't talk about
enough is the cage you put yourself in
emotion
this has been hey
march online right now go get our merch
it's all out right now
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings bae don't be
afraid don't be ashamed don't hesitate
to say hey babe hey babe hey babe hey